CHANCES.
NONE YET FOR THE LIGHTNING.
CERNAK.
CENTERING PASS.
RIGHT IN THE SLOT BY PALAT. EAR.
ROOM FOR BRIAN BOYLE, TRYING TO
JAM IT IN.
HEDMAN PLAYED A LOT LAST0 FOR H
CAREER, GAINING RAPIDLY ON RAY
FERRARO ON THE TEAM, THAT
FIRST GAME, IT'S ALL POSSIBLE.
SEUCKER
BACK AFTER HE LIMPED OFF
EARLIER,
SLOPPY PLAY BY VASILEVSKIY, AND
IT WAS CEN
TERRIFIC PLAY TO SEAL THE WALL.
AND VASILEVSKIY TRIES TO THROW
IT AROUND THE B CONTINUES TO BE
AMAZING STORY, AND A TRYOUT FOR
FOR TAMPA BAY. POSITION ALL THE.
RODRIGUES.
DOWN LOW.
AND IT'S RIGHT IN FRONT TO
POINT, WHO DIDN'
STILL SCORELESS ON THE NIGHT AND
FROM BRITISH COLUMBIA.
WENT TO HOFSTRA TO PLAY
LACROSSE.
A
DRAFTED ORIGINALLY BY THE
PHILADELPHIA FLYERS.
DOMINIK SIMON JUST THREW IT
LE
PLAYER IN FRONT OF THE NET
IT
POINT.
IT MIGHT HAVE HIT SOMEBODY OUT
IN FRONT.
I THINK THAT'S
AROUND THE BOARD.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE HEDMAN AND
STAMKOS CLOSE TOGETHER.
AND ENTERTAINING AS IT COULD BE.
NET EMPTY AGAGA THE SWEET DISH
FROM STAMKOS.
HE FEATHERS THIS PASS
GOAL FOR PITTSBURGH. THIS
LOOSE PUCK.
IT'S CHIPPED UP THE WALL, AND IN
A RUMORED DESTINATION.
BUT THEY JUST SIGNEDED